yeah hello dr. Wallach this is a quick
deal for me I've been one of your
associates now for 17 years and I've got
a thanks for being pardon lammle yeah
I've got a mother-in-law who's 82 years
old who's got some major problems here
four years ago she was diagnosed with
stage 4 colon cancer and which moved
into her liver and lymph at lymph nodes
the colon cancer was surgically removed
and the colon was reattached so there
was no bag
she took the ID chemo and now they got
her on chemo pills but she said so I
have to take for life and now her elf
has been in steady decline and now
having issues with severe pain starting
in the right hand growing area and
moving around the back repair anyway
about 150 160 pounds okay all right you
have cancer your best friend is your
immune system unfortunately chemotherapy
fails 97 percent of the time this actual
statistics put out by the American
Cancer Society and also chemotherapy
does kill cancer cells it also kills
normal cells okay so you need to support
the immune system and support the body's
ability to defend itself and maintain
the healthy tissue - so 152 pounds 150
pounds Charmaine what would you suggest
for a supplement program for John's
mother-in-law what at her weight I would
suggest for those issues that she has I
would suggest she takes two healthy
brain and hard packs and I would add to
that the few Koide the orange or the Z
radical and the oceans gold mm-hmm okay
very very good and chars exactly right
you know she's got to get rid of all the
bad foods and you've been with us a long
time John so you know that no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens and there's still plenty to eat
okay with all that takeaway stuff but
it's going to save a lot of money but
getting rid of the bad foods and
the Shar says you want to get her on two
healthy brain and heart packs full dose
of breakfast and dinner time that's
going to give her body and all of her
tissues everything they need to support
maintenance repair of everything plus
supports immune system okay and ninety
cents of nutrients and then let's see
here char what else did you throw in
there
oceans gold and radical or oh yeah yeah
yeah okay
oceans gold that's for for what what an
oceans always valuable to support your
immune system yeah the sea cucumber for
cancer patients
legendary wonderful articles written up
in the Wall Street Journal it's really
great stuff and so I never take it her
body weight she could take three of
those tablets twice a day two bottles a
month of the oceans gold and if she's
really not into taking lots of counsels
and pills I didn't ever take the Z
radical liquid so she could take two
ounces a day one of breakfast one or
dinner time that's going to give her
three of the super juices to support her
immune system and few Clayton which is a
extract of red marine algae from off the
east coast of of Australia and the
island of Tasmania and actually is what
the Japanese a tribute to their having a
lesser cancer rate than we do and also
to a higher rate of survival cancer than
we do they attributed to the sea
coroner's actually 850 university
studies on this stuff because
everybody's one to get in on the science
of it because it does have such a great
history of supporting the immune system
is supporting the health and longevity
cancer patients and then of course again
stayin away from the bad stuff is
imperative and you know have fun that
are read with the kids and all that kind
of stuff and make sure she's included
and moms and grandmom's and so forth do
well at the very least we're going to
give her a higher quality of life and
extended her life but we just you know
it's up to her body and the good Lord if
she's
survive this it's possible but she's
gonna have to do a lot of work this is
something that takes a lot of effort you
got to be obsessive about it and
avoiding the bad stuff there cannot be
any cheat days everyone in the
households got to stay away from the bad
stuff she's so she's not cross
contaminating the laundry pouches our
food preparation services call us in
regular basis if you would hear John
give us an update